[Music]
for e
have
release my chest should be
help you for now BR your right hand
close sometimes we overdrive with the
B makes that happen come back a
take tension off the right you need to
move
back okay try don't round your back
don't cave your chest
don't tilt your pelvis
up head positions exactly like Salan the
chin is slightly tucked crown of the
head is the top of your
posture and mid foot
weight send the tip out keep the
long chest
out inner thighs
out arch your posture with your legs
tension release the legs the feet
so UND do my
exercise settle and she's just going to
give a little pressure you're not going
to fence on the
tip
push just
let's go
quickly I
don't let's try
[Music]
first he's going to do the releasing on
his
own can gradually increase
pressure don't lean
forward don't pick it up Margaret F your
your body so you can push straight in
down the
sword Margaret that grip's going to push
down Virginia have your sword parallel
to the ground don't let her pick it
up just keep
releasing don't pick up their sword
and then release
quick is at the bottom of the
C not doing
that so don't get in some weird thing
well this works for me
convenient do what the did when the
teacher demonstrated
try your weight
come pass the midot
fre yes heels came off
like
on going switch rolls
now move your body so you don't change
the vector
gradually
increase
for e
when one time is good you just
when you come off come off come off
don't come off gradually just take it
away the the metric isn't whether you
fall
forward the metric is does your weight
shift
forward that's what I'm talking about so
you didn't go flying forward but you you
corrected as you were going that's still
my weight is not going down my weight is
pushing against the force okay so the
weight Shift come off your heels all
that kind of stuff that's indicative
that your force your counter force is
against the other Force rather than that
Force coming in and going down okay try
it
again start with settling your own
matter your own gravitational force on
the foot you're going to add their
lateral Force to that same
line let them do it first it might take
a
while just some pretty straight legs for
the bottom of the cut
you're going to get your arms tired
there so finish the cut first the cut is
going to end with the Suka one fist with
the weight there you go and all that
settles or back's not rounded anymore
good Gra gradually increase
release the arm tension
I don't know why that sword flipped
up you see it flip up at the
finish the cut the cut
finishes
for for
okay uh
Now find this a lot
harder let go quickly and let's see what
happens there you go
hch your stomach round your back cave
your chest in same thing gradually
increasing pressure goes very
high as fast as you can you take that
maximum pressure off
fr maximum pressure
maximum increase increas
inrease I
AG
P same way Sensei with the backgrounded
yeah with the backgrounded
cave your chest you don't have to
do your neck and Chin just cave the
chest round the shoulders
forward increase increase increase
increase increase increase
start
the release
all
start driving more and
more that's R
right let the tension go please pay
the for
driving more than yesterday more than
the day
before drive drive drive drive drive you
okay all the side be careful
fatigue if if you want to bring in more
bracing angle you can go for for it
we're working with
NGA don't push your hand down just like
the sword tip straight in lateral
Force don't over articulate the elbows
stay in
katate keep l g driving you're going to
take a external
push going to increase the force
Christ chist chist chist chist chist
chist
push push push push push push push
with thecreed inity is it trigger me
back into this or as he's driving can I
continue the same
mechanics and reached higher levels of
release let's go
fast try try so I I know I'm that's what
we do you you generate the likelihood of
the uncultivated behavior to
the cultivated Behavior okay try try
again what it feel
like did
[Music]
it no I was
trying probably I don't know if I could
have gotten any
Force um did he get
tiring yes
it was interesting that uh as You
released there was no space
differential change between us but I
kept it kept getting lower and lower and
lower that was bizarre yeah and you you
will get you will feel even that you got
more into me although you didn't really
move towards me okay that and that's
what we want okay
and it's a skill so it's not a it's not
a state you reach once and for all he's
every time you push my mind goes
then you have to release it okay and you
release it and now you you can feel
those deeper more unconscious levels of
tension and contestation okay but so UK
is our tool here UK is our our Barb they
got to be a good one okay so try it
again
you're not train you're yesterday I had
you UK do what nag is doing today I'm
not today you're you're not going to do
the you're it's like you saw Chris okay
gra you're probably going to push over
some nggas it's fine
come on Margaret use your muscles don't
let her rotate you right
now
now again release is not
relaxation just let go of that
muscle without changing shape
again you're not doing it Virginia you
are trying to knock him
backwards bend your bend your back knee
more to the Y State knee to toe
put your mass on that mid fooot before
you offer your
hand don't let the elbow articulation
change
the elbow is that's an external yield we
want just an internal yield now
El inside the
shoulder hand
don't
elbow come
out relas your again
yes
AAL take this off keep the same feel the
keep it keep it don't sit that up on
your spine don't do
that St back up it's going over the fo
there you
go yout out elbow stays in release the
glutes not the arm just the glutes
good
okay um
what what what do you think happened
there CU I pushing how much you
weigh
130 okay I got 50 lb on her probably lot
more musle she's knocking you over
earlier now I'm not knocking you over
what do you think happened
I'm definitely feeling you know tension
yeah that way keep TI yeah um but
not my biceps and form SP right
okay did you feel when you would release
the glutes and we all get lower
that was so subtle it's very subtle you
tell me to release my know they were
engaged not and I would think about
releasing try to release them yeah no
maybe maybe the film would catch it I
don't know yeah they said they could see
you sink a little okay I could
definitely feel the sinking I got
pressed down too okay uh but it is
subtle and so
um when we talk about subtlety what are
we really talking about our ability to
perceive it really right it's a it's
relative
subtlety is it subtle to me or is it
gross to me for them observing it was a
gross movement for
you trying to feel whether it was tense
or not it's a subtle movement for me I
could tell when the when the glutes are
are tight because I'm more just pushing
this way I could feel that but when you
would drop then I would feel my energy
kind of go down on you I'm just making
you heavier and then you'd come up did
feel associated with the arm so you
would bring your elbow out back to where
you
fell this is where I'm supposed to
be and we come back
up so we start all over and we go back
down again you see
um all right try try for these things
okay go if you have questions any
questions
um not articulate questions just just
just just yeah just talk cuz uh I think
I like how you said it like you wanted
to come learn what red is from my
example like I'm trying to explain red
to somebody who's not seen it before
if we wait if if we could formulate the
questions then we know what red is so no
that doesn't work you have to just what
feels like
rambling what do you
got I don't know I I you know clearly
good guidance because it just I felt in
incoming Force but it just all felt to
me like adjustments you
know definitely like I said some tension
in the arm but not yes yeah you know not
like you would think for that level of
press lateral pressure well and that's
that's part of it too I've got no sense
of which I suppose is the goal no sense
of how much Lal pressure feel like much
yeah it doesn't feel like much yeah
didn't feel like nothing it didn't feel
like much yeah and and you when you
would
drop I I like the word pressure because
I do feel pressurized and I feel like
he's he's really deep into the intern
inside you so if I move he's going to
move if I if I release and yield he's
going to come flying in you know what I
mean you you brought like a balloon that
you squished you see or I like the
analogy of the ball the the beach ball
that you bring under the pool surface
water that's what it feels like okay it
feels like I I now control what happens
to this ball okay and it is pressure but
it's not the I'm against you muscular
tension so yeah there is there
is a sense of something greater
happening but it's different from the
what we want to normally do right Flex
against it we start fatiguing pretty
much like what we're doing as not as UK
UK is doing what we usually do that's
why I said UK is not training and we're
not doing what we usually do so I you do
feel a greatness or a pressure you do
feel the force but you don't feel it
exactly like the who kids doing now when
they're pushing like my I said my grip
and my biceps are tired but my grip and
biceps weren't tired at all when he was
pushing on me I didn't feel that at all
okay I would say this
too
um the fact that I knowingly
flex and then
suddenly
unflexed is again what is very important
is how sensitive am I how aware how do I
have in the contestation behavior in the
flexion you see that's very very
important and this why you can't really
separate that mind and body because the
body will do things totally outside of
our awareness just it'll just do it okay
um and so part of this is yeah we have
to gain this sensitivity to what is
going on so it's not so settle so it's
gross and we understand what's
happening um now imagine that that you
never had that
experience whatsoever okay so I left you
entirely with Virginia pushing you over
just pushing you over you
see or I didn't give
you the
initial Vector through your body for
your body to realize look it's there's a
dness to this to see that the shoulder
hand right shoulder stabilization and
the pressure design and it wasn't that
great it was nowhere near on the grip
it's just here get to your here okay and
then once you felt that when that went
away there's no more pushing on you it's
you descending do you see and then you
between the glutes flexing and we went
to lateral contestation and then the
glutes relaxing in the contrast you're
building up that sensitivity you see
um but imagine you never had that
experience then no one really knows what
we're talking about in that grou right
like I hardly feel like I have had the
experience it feels like two completely
different exercises yes
yeah I don't know that I've be able to
you're probably not because because it's
a skill and the teacher gu you you there
into it with his own energetics until I
can leave you alone in it this goes back
to like yesterday I if even if I choose
to save you you're not saved I saved you
you have to save yourself so this has to
become your thing but now we have an
experience you see and now it's a little
easier to to orient ourselves towards
that okay so as I would go on with the
practice uh I would use the the teacher
said careful on the elbow this this is
your old youth okay so keep the elbow
in teacher also said keep extending the
only way my elbow goes out if I stop
extending you see the hand comes back to
me but if I keep my hand out there then
the elbow won't go out okay and the
elbow will stay in the Y Line also the
teacher kept saying go back to your
glutes go back to your glutes back to
your gles and you can for the time being
imagine the teacher's hand on your on
your shoulder there okay go back to the
glutes go back to the glutes extend the
hand ex the go back to the glut back why
this will work is when you Flex the
glutes you Flex a bunch of other parts
of your body okay and when we hit the
glutes all those other parts those
pushing contestant parts they will also
release okay um so let's try it and see
what happens okay it is there yeah
you always take this like that
okay she's always stronger
she body you go like
this you're not paying ATT
your your drill is not
her your drill is
you start doing this
okay um for me it's not going to matter
no stay where you are okay or which
angle are you pushing yeah push
into his structure don't push around the
stret I'll show you what you're
doing you're going around the stret push
into his
structure see so this is your sword you
push straight down
the don't push it around your structure
okay
try and the goal is the
releasing
not not not being pushed over extend
your hand extend your hand extend your
hand extend your hand hand extend extend
extend more more ad extend your
hand go back to your glutes Every
Time Break Down The Sword to
destruction have lower leg
release it start at the glutes again go
down to the
[Music]
leg
off all
right doing the ding I'm doing the same
grounding I'm going to move oh don't go
fine on me please you don't have to do
anything you're here
when I walk I'm walking the same
way my weight goes on that
foot on the
midot are going to have you
pull this is more of K
hey can you do this with with the energy
that I want to work with
okay why did you why do you keep going
okay let's try okay
all
right no you're p
when you put your foot down put your
weight on the mid
fooot to
midot turn the
F shift your weight to the back
step onto that right mid foot step onto
the other midot
and then the I gave to
the so I'm
pushing
then she's she's trying to get me
you see if I step I'm seeking
control she has to move my body just
like I moved Ronan when I chopped him in
the neck she has to move my body now we
learn she's tilting me he's pinning my
foot right
it if I at the slightest
attempt step I have my balance back and
it's never revealed her that she's
tilting
me okay you don't have to move you you
have to grab per prescription you have
to keep your grip so I have a decent bar
and you have to spinally
displace okay that's all you
do good see she regained her balance did
you see did you get that you don't have
to do that we're not throwing you okay
and then I have to move you
down I have to move your
body this as you
can you don't have to do anything
except push grip don't seek control okay
good what you're
doing but you Mar walks around
you walk around me please it looks like
it's
it
no this the difference yes
okay so you do that and I can continue
to teach okay I want her to go around me
this
way she's got to go over
here I make go around me
then I
enter and I am now looking at the new 9
okay so if you started at 12 with the
right
side you're going to look at
three okay right if you're on the left
six don't
look at
six you got more to
do okay
try your right foot will be
here for
use use both hands to control the rate
the radius and the acceleration so as
much as energy is bringing him around is
also not letting them go past okay try
it
again for
Okay so
yesterday I used the center in the on
thees everyone
so here don't be in his
arm he
driving gather here move this part
forward okay when it gets to your Jing
line the center of your chest that is
where the other hand takes
over takes over and does the same
keeps that
going don't get out of the way you're
pushing please push don't get out of the
way he falls
in hence why Virginia can pull and he's
still coming in okay you understand okay
so feel the same energy that you felt
here and you
ground okay you got to push same enery
I am moving it around you can't go past
it push can't go past it can't pull it I
move it into Center okay same thing here
when I get here I have to move that
Center then I move into that space I I'm
not moving into that space to turn him
he creates that space
here and I step freely into
it mid foot Shing takes
over
moves this hand will bring his neck to
the J there again and I use the two
hands moving there and I freely step in
that space okay try it
control how much he go
so again don't turn him on the
entry do do you get it yes
okay turn him on the solid
base and you step freely on the
entry there should be no more turn of
her on the turn on the entry
turn in there step in the freely without
turning him more
you're turning
her keep your
feet I move this way
solid solid solid solid just like just
like the the
first so the first Dr I'm solid and as I
move I'm still doing all that midot
stuff
solid solid okay same same projection
ability you see from there I'm not going
to float
around solid okay so it's the same
drill here weit down weight down weight
down only now it's moving it's moving
moving moving
here okay
try midfoot weight
solid
solid solid and
relax solid means the same release
skills as drill
two no no no right foot enter
step in the back position of Advantage
the
back right foot
in you're doing a ten con with your left
foot with your right foot
sorry bring past you take stop now your
right foot is going to enter so your
body's facing me here don't turn any
turn BR up there he is okay stay in the
back go
that's it and the technique right
there go around you you enter into the
fre space
don't don't walk
around
yes yes
we're not we're not doing
nugget nugget we're doing a grounding
exercise
stand for
tension on all
right UK is not walking around for
us trying to get their
balance stay on the outside of the arm
ground ground ground n that's too
muchi same push
stri and then stay on the outside of the
arm don't cut on the there you go
use the head once the hand gets to the
juming both are doing
it move it to down now go do it that's
it all
right moving
Center getting away from the arm and
shoulder the center
all this is this
uh kind of like remember on the Poke
hole like I'm not knocking him down I'm
not sending him back right it was a
different
geometry um but it's so ubiquitous it's
knock down and send back that that feels
right and that feels like the only thing
I can
do but as we saw it exposes your elbow
right sending back that's not
working alone
theorized through sound Theory that's
that's we're just overpowering that okay
so this is another very common
one uh
rotation
okay um we don't rotate the hips in
iido we move the quaw this is the amount
of rotation that I
get that's it that quaw
movement is the same one
here we just gave it a number it's 15
of rotation we didn't actually measure
it okay so we just call it
15 the idea that I can
turn half you see with hip rotation is
ulous in ik
every technique has it but it doesn't
understand Force
okay so here her hands on my head here
her hand is
there and she's going to
enter and turn my body in the technique
got it everyone got that
okay so she's going to
enter stop
okay hold
it you can even hold it with two hand
don't
try hold
the and you're going
to let you do this
first
ready you are you sure you understand
what part is that in
the do I look like
I'm okay so notice when she loses her
balance it's at the part
where here okay even not a littleit okay
turn pull pull stay
there and turn your hips and pull
me try this
experiment figure out how to get in our
point of the technique
together to get to the starting
point how about you just start the
technique and before you do the ENT and
turn you stop okay so get the
technique then you
stop he's going to go the other
the you know where you are or you lost I
got
yeah so go back where you are stay there
let
go you're it's going to go around you
hey stop it's going to go around you
okay keep it there I have to be here
cing
here she's pulling the rotational Force
she go
okay did you see what you had to do what
you have to
do stop you stop turning you see okay I
want you to turn you're going to lose
your
balance okay got it okay you you can't
turn which is what she did okay but I
want you to experience it all right try
it I'll tell you what from a teacher I
got this person trying to regain their
balance I got this person that won't
lose their balance I got this person who
sometimes is going to push and not push
it's all that controll
again okay this is my middle right
middle of the dojo what's the difference
the the skill ukas are F being out of
control we're not throwing you there's
really no danger here
okay go make yourself vulnerable
you're you're going to be the the
counter rotation to his rotation
so it's going to go around you you're
the nogin okay and you're going to pull
him into the
rotation sorry I put your hand on the
wrong side but you fix your hand
just pull pull the Joe around you pull
it around you like you would that
okay okay are youing
this and I'm
not I don't think you guys are
understanding
this is just Newton's
law
okay you guys heard of him
right it's the opposite and equal
reaction law
States for every Force you do it
generates the opposite inal
reaction your internal aspects are are a
way around that don't generate an
opposite Force because you're you're
generating the
contestation got that
okay
so when you are trying to take 's body
into this curve that's a force
line that means there's a force line
going the other
way got it
okay she's going to take me you're going
to do the turn I going to get me to
where you turn and you're going to turn
okay now you're going to turn me with
your turn turn me with your turn you see
got
it that's the part we're talking
about come on come on come on come on
come on okay are you ready to turn me
with your turn Okay one more time I'll
show you the part we're talking about
she goes
get there please okay this hand is
generating that
Force there is going to be an equal and
opposite reaction to that
Force whether the
person is even fighting against it or
not you get it okay watch what you feel
on this hand on the pressure increasing
as you turn that's all I'm asking you to
do you're going to inter turn turn and I
just want you to feel pressure right now
what's it at give it a variable and then
you go pressure
increase okay do it again that's the
opposite Force okay you come around
again come on please okay there we are I
don't know where you are
okay I do not step into this to get
control watch your pressure watch your
pressure
go if it wasn't not the same level was
it I'm seeking
control I won't do it you'll feel you'll
have to move me you'll feel the pressure
the okay
and we're going to wait for her to move
okay I'm not with her I this is
not being moved do you understand pay
attention to where the quit came into
your mind like it's not going to work
okay where on the rotation does it
happen that's what we want to know
okay where in the rotation okay
good you see cuz here's that
Force got it and that force is to
exponentially right I'll show you right
now here's that Force right where is it
going in between her Bas of support you
see that okay and as you turn nope you
already turning as she turns that gets
worse okay and that's what you're
experiencing in the job why don't I
experience it in in ukim because is
trying to get control see that now what
we
want is for them he goes
and we do want that we want the
resistance if there was no resistance
right if I'm here end technique end
technique but there is resistance okay
we do want that leg take him make him
have to do that he'll put his leg there
and then that counter force is going to
be even stronger as you can't rotate so
what I am recommending is here this is
qua
15 then step freely no more rotation
now you're in the
B okay so this will be our
drill right doing the grounding
still boom juming L CH both hands pick
up she goes around
there is this free space I step into it
front arm your
triangle okay try good no more
rotation you step freely into it you
will not be strong on those
Circle Tap early nobody better see black
as soon as you feel pressure in your ear
you tap
you had that all jacked up get your mind
in
here step freely into the back with it
actual Ed me all
right don't turn her there and you don't
turn
there three
times
last around
quad One Step choke okay try it again
[Music]
see I got 15 all right use it
I sure he can good in here so you pass
so I step so
I
go you going have the ground you use the
clock
CL step really then CH step freely then
CH CLA step freely then choke what I
mean by freely is don't try to
manipulate mass on your rotation just
step into space okay
the mass is manipulated on the cross
see qu step
freely
qu step freely
the hand
hand you you're changing the footwork to
use the quad you have to be grounded not
moving
right you enter after You' moved him
with the
claw
don't rotate just get
15 move them past you good step
freely you're behind them
quad step freely look how I least leave
you where you are
in position drop your elbow kneel down
fre drop my
elbow
try Don't Let Go him I'm just showing
Chris that I'm not manipulating you when
I enter just enter keep your hands where
they were don't manipula
drop your elbow kneel
down in your
freely drop your
elbow kneel
down enter
freely elbow
Drops Keep it a little Lo say you drop
your elbow so you can keep the whole
form going go drop the elbow down
good B enter freely yes
ground drop your elbow and your steros
kneel down
so when you do this
manuver you come around here don't turn
him this elbow you go straight
down don't turn it it's going down okay
sinking that cheat if you don't move
though they'll run into you okay so
you're going down down both and now he's
hanging himself right right okay and
then when I come down I'm going to shove
his chin forward into the
choke okay don't rotate him don't step
back to pull him down elbow's going to
compromise his
posture and just like uh reconciliation
from last night
get out of the way so he hangs himself
for little B for a second it tightens
everything up and then the final one is
forward okay
try down don't let it turn on you
elbow hang down
forward elbow
fre elbow don't pull
backwards drop him down then hang them
don't pull them
backwards he'll fall he'll fall or the
train fir will accelerate here
okay think about having his butt hit the
ground sit
elbow elbow
down let him sit push him
forward not just his chin not his body
ready to drop the elbow into your spine
feel that there's almost like a
forwardness to it right as opposed to
the back there's a forwardness to
it keep here's the hand that
this comes back
still okay try
it no acceleration backwards
crunch
them hang them well you're trying to
shove them down
if I crunch him he's going to fall down
I'm not shutting him
down he falls down then I can hang him
if I'm pushing him
down not hanging him it would be like
cutting the back of his neck as he's
running past
okay all right so now let us do this
technique without the choke
okay same technique but where we started
you me not get set up okay try it
again don't go back
to move the claw move them past you
enter without turning them anymore move
them past you
enter you have to bring them around on
the CL
okay then ENT turn enter ent ent what
you it okay just don't move in
anym turn
good ground ground ground watch our feet
angle 45 to 90 is our only Spectrum
don't open it past the
90 try not to grab be on the
outside on the outside
yes and
then fre keep your
position okay so now as long as you
don't stop it looks like what you're
doing you see but if you pay attention
she's not rotating on the turn
[Music]
okay see if you can shorten the pauses
the pauses are coming from the flex
which is pinning you as you move them
you're pinning her you're pinning you
and if you were
released then you could
step okay you see that you don't you're
just pinning yourself that's why you're
pinning you're flexing and so you need
to wait for the weight to come off her
weight before you
move but if you're
grounding she can stay in constant
movement okay
try how do you ground just like little
two
try not to let him stop is what we're
working on now without going back to
turning the claw doesn't go past doesn't
go past me there's a rotation to the
claw do you see it doesn't go like that
so he doesn't go like that he comes
around look at my arms what happens as I
pass the 90 on my arm lever does it get
shorter or longer shorter shorter which
means he comes around me just bring them
around you bring them around you you
keep shoving them away from you okay
go don't turn her on that part right we
just wasted the whole last half
hour keep them moving inter free yes yep
and then settle release all tension all
desire settle
again
okay enter a little earlier cuz it's
getting a little twisted you can enter
to untwist the qua
okay he's already off you so you can
enter
freely that's it and relax
[Music]
okay keep for
moving other
foot we want the back where I can choke
them there you go keep them keep them on
this side keep him on that side of you
yes okay try it
again don't pull him back towards
you
good thank you other